es la mayor mina de carbón a cielo
abierto de américa latina el cerrejón en
el noreste de columbia es superado por
la empresa suiza glencore y produce
altísimas cantidades de este combustible
fusil del año 1000 de 2021 de todo se
recompone 23.4
tras el embargo energético ruso alemana
planea comprar más carbón colombiano
katrin en berger diputada del partido
verde alemán se desplazó al lugar para
investigar las condiciones de esta
enorme producción
toda la mina tiene un impacto
considerable en la región en términos de
suministro de agua potable pero también
en términos de contaminación del aire
sin embargo los representantes de la
empresa minera afirman que no hay ningún
impacto negativo en el medio ambiente la
mina tiene un impacto significativo en
la región en términos de suministro de
agua potable y también de contaminación
del aire la empresa minera por supuesto
me dice que todo está perfecto y que lo
tiene bajo control pero durante nuestra
visita no hicieron explotación por lo
que intentan que todo quede perfecto
pero como soy una aficionada al tema
conozco la diferencia refrendó la mina
utiliza 24 millones de litros de agua al
día en parte para rociar las carreteras
y los envíos de carbón sin embargo la
guajira es una región semidesértica
donde el agua escasea
cerca del perímetro del cerrejón viven
comunidades indígenas wayú la empresa ha
desviado el curso de este río para
ampliar sus operaciones
alterando el ecosistema de la región
para que la empresa llego al agua no
falla
la comida no fue
cuánto muchachos no se han muerto por
falta del agua
verdad así que me sorprende mucho saber
que las comunidades siguen amenazadas de
desalojo tenemos que salir del carbón y
tenemos que hacerlo a nivel
internacional ayuda
el 7 de agosto por primera vez en la
historia tomará posesión un presidente
de izquierda en colombia gustavo petro
aboga por una transición energética pero
también necesita reponer las arcas del
estado y el embargo de la energía rusa
representa una ventaja para los países
productores como colombia por el momento
el freno a la minería del carbón no está
en la agenda